[Music]
hello everybody hello hey wait there's
nobody here yet
oh there's one hello y'all um so hey
it's a it is not even like we're gonna
have a long amount of time between the
next fat man on Batman [ __ ] I got us up
saying that it's so it's so engrained in
my head
the next fat man beyond the first fat
man beyond but yeah we're not gonna have
a bunch of time before the next one we
were taping on Saturday and then telling
another on Tuesday but I figured I got
like a like 45 minutes to kill before
this thing that I got to go do I'm here
in the office the fancy Treadstone
office which looks like it's none more
white and [ __ ] on the wall there's
secret things over in that corner but
yeah I figured I'm here let's have some
questions so q any time who's got a
thing they want to know tell me
something tell me something who's Terry
who's Bruce in this duo
I mean clearly I'm Terry come on man I
mean Frankenstein with a three in there
we would I'm clearly Terry he's gonna be
the matador chubbie Bruce Wayne he yells
at me in the corner to keep my mic high
all right coffee and bro nuts
realistically who do you think you'd be
cast in a superhero film on the other
hand who would I love to play well
anybody can be a superhero clearly if
you're gonna ask me if who I'd like to
play in a superhero movie I would like
to play Amanda Waller
it'll never happen I would need to
transition first but I think she's
pretty boss hey bagel drivin let's see
henry cavill my thoughts um I will
reserve most of those for the first fat
man beyond but I will say that I think
he was not done any favors by the movies
he was Superman in everywhere double O
one listen to what went wrong with a new
predator film I don't know haven't seen
it yet
I will say that while I have been a
massive Shane black fan I was not a
massive fan of the nice guys you know I
liked Iron Man 3 but not because it was
ashamed like movie per se but because
you gave me another Iron Man movie but I
loved Kiss Kiss Bang Bang I love them
most of the things he's written
but yeah it's a without I'll have to
reserve judgment till I see the movie
but um but yeah not entirely sure not
entirely sure who do I want to replace
Henry Cavill that will also be something
that that I talk about the next fat man
Beyond but I also think that my Kobe
joint is an interesting choice let's see
Alexander Thorpe how would I feel in
Captain Marvel get the Marvel who takes
that if you're Zack if he thinks he's a
Skrull that would be pretty friggin red
I would I would yeah [ __ ] it yeah
somebody should take out his eye let's
say future booth game most of the future
of DC movies it seems as if they are
sort of reexamining their plan their
slate they're their reason for existence
which seems to be as they've discovered
the future is female as far as DC is
concerned one women 84 is happening a
Supergirl is a big priority
aside from Shazam and Aquaman they are
leaning very heavily on that stuff the
Harley Quinn movie whatever that's going
to be birds of prey which is you know
honestly fine do that be be the thing
that the other company isn't being you
know be something new in the world and
and to to build your shiny superhero
universe around women I mean you could
make a far worse decision some might
argue that you already have so again do
you see do that let me see Jerry we are
once you know who sits on the Iron
Throne
right now at Searcy now if the question
was who will end up on the Iron Throne
by the end of it I mean I want Aria Aria
saria's won all of the things she's
earned my heart she's positively badass
so yeah I go I go Aria trappy Jenkins
hey Mike Gladstone you can't stop me man
you can't stop me dance that's John Hamm
is Batman why not I think I've depends
on the Batman he won because he's an old
dude at this point and by old dude I
mean he's like 40-something which means
that how many more bad movies are gonna
get before he's too old and the reason
why you know I mean even have like is
probably a little bit older than they
would have wanted to go with but yeah I
mean Jon Hamm has the sort of older
Batman the same Batman that that Ben
Affleck played sure but if you want a
young Batman who's gonna carry this for
the next 10 years you know you want to
get a guy who's was Chris Hemsworth or
Chris Evans his age when they started as
as Thor and Iron Man respectively so you
want somebody in their late 20s and I
don't so you don't know who that guy is
but yeah I'm not sure boom 9 if I try
the new spider-man game thoughts I tried
it I didn't play very long I played for
maybe half an hour I kind of dug in I
mean the fighting stuff reminds me a bit
of Arkham Asylum they might just put
spider-man in in a space and have him
fight bad guys in a way that makes sense
in the way that takes advantage of his
agility I'm having gotten into the story
yet so I'm not sure how dense or deep
that is but I had a good time for a
little bit that I played I've been
trying to split my time and nights
between writing and spider-man and Iron
Fist season 2 so hopefully I'll get
deeper in this coming week let me see
Bridget FA what comic book would you
recommend for a woman who loves the
stories but as a hard time focus in love
reading comic books
but no problems with thousand
novels I would recommend why the last
man I would recommend fables I would
recommend the Sandman I would recommend
preacher yeah I mean I think that those
there's there's a lot in both of those
and all for those things that I
recommend it to you there's a lot of
book there there's a lot of story there
but they're all they don't require
knowledge of anything else they don't
require you to have this continuity mind
of remember you know where was that man
this issue but they're all wonderful
stories are all incredibly well
constructed they're all narrative ly and
structurally knife flawless and and
especially Sandman is one of my favorite
literate literary experiences of all
time I was reading Sandman
so yes can I recommend that highly
enough um let's see everywhere the below
one what do I think about David Gordon
greens halloween ignoring the sequel
smart move
yeah you know at this point you cannot
count on people coming to your sequel to
a thing that was already like six years
old to a thing that was a sequel to a
fifth sequel of a thing that started in
1977 and remember any of it so make it
its own thing at this point make it its
own
everybody loves the first one everybody
remembers the basics of that first one I
don't need to know what happened in
Halloween four four on the floor or
Halloween five stayin alive all you got
to know is
here's Michael Myers who's Larry Stroud
here's what happened in 25 years later
or whatever that was so yeah that's
that's I think it makes a ton of sense
let's see doctors a 2099 wants to know
what it's like working with Kevin Smith
a little smoky but pretty good I have a
good time
Pete Pete wants to know when we're
getting the next movie commentary I
don't know Pete soon as I hope I I
always have a good time doing them but
they are they are labor labor intensive
but yeah I don't think it'll be for too
long I don't think you'll have to wait
too long
this may help anyway big McGee I'll
allow it but you watch your step like
guy Asian food or Mexican food and
Mediterranean food when I was in New
York it would have been Asian food but
now that I'm in LA Mexican food
although I do like a good ito every now
and again let's see two nerds in the
basement do I give any shits about this
Shazam movie I didn't before I saw the
trailer I'll be honest
didn't quite guess you Sam was never my
guy really like I liked what they did
with him I came in coming that would
mark Wade and Alex roster with Emma
Kingdom come but he was never my go-to
here I would never buy a Shazam comic
book but you know to tell me that you're
gonna make it like my bodyguard but it's
a superhero that's pretty read that it's
gonna be a sweet comedy that's pretty
read yeah so I'm I'm cautiously
optimistic
so yeah let's see the Peter Sherlock
thank you for the congrats on Castle
Rock the response has been like
heartening and not quite embarrassing
what I'm sure the Germans have a word
for that feeling of you know so much
enthusiasm for a thing that you hope
they would have enthusiasm for but that
much enthusiasm is making you feel a
little bashful so yeah that that's the
word and yeah I will totally check out
the DC Universe service I'm very curious
about Titans I have a couple of friends
who were working on that show so yeah I
would like to see what they're up to
I am chase Bell any chance you would
read a pilot of mine in your spare time
would love your thoughts so here's the
thing I'm chase Bell this is in no way
directed at you per se you just happen
to be the person asked the question
[Music]
first but definitely not the biggest
reason is there's not a ton of spare
time in my life
the time then I'm not spending in the
room there's time that I'm working on my
own stuff and the till I'm not spending
work on my own stuff is time I'm
spending with my family
and those two last things can flip-flop
depending on the week so there there's
the the hours and the day are not mine
or not on my side more importantly is
that legally it is very very hard for me
to read something that somebody else
wrote because it opens oneself up to any
number of challenges and lawsuits and
issues and general headaches in a life
that has probably more headaches that I
needed to have already anyway because
who's to say that I am not already
working on a story or an idea that is in
the same arena as the thing that you're
working on if I read your pilot and say
hey I like it but make these 19 changes
and you go off and do that and great and
then and then my thinning cells you
could theoretically have some sort of
claim saying that I read your piece of
work and was inspired by it and
incorporated some ideas that you had
into my own thing which I would like to
believe is not true it would not be true
but it suddenly makes it a case it
suddenly makes it an issue that we have
to deal with whether or not you know you
sue me and I win whether or not you sue
me and I lose life is simpler if that is
just not a thing that I do and most if
not every professional writer you talk
to you will have the same response to
you because while we love the fact that
that you know people are writing stuff
on their own people are creating stuff I
mean if Kevin's an evangelist for
anything it's it's do your own [ __ ] make
your own thing find a way to put your
voice in the world and that's amazing
but it is it is it is fraught for me to
become involved in any way with that
thing that you want to make into the
world except there's a consumer and if
you get to make it I'll buy it if you do
a Kickstarter for it I'll support it if
you put it up online I'll share it but
you know it is it is just it is it is a
a dark winding road for me to walk down
and there are terrors at every turn so
yes unfortunately I'm sorry I am
Bell but good luck no Merrill I will not
answer that question yeah let's see
Anthony's art works what music album of
any genre do you make a movie out of I
do Queens Queen 2 album because it has a
Fant as you feel
pardon my finger what album of any genre
would I want to adapt and make like it I
suppose you wanted to be a concept album
right but that's the case I would do
Janelle monáe's archandroid she's been
doing some amazing work in telling sort
of afro-futurist extort ease in a
musical space and and there's a lot
there's a lot of ideas there about a an
Android that that comes to life so yeah
that's what I would do
let's see Josh Jones are the classic
music movies you think it could be
remade for a new century you know trying
to thing off the top of my head the
problem is is that I don't want to
remake jobs I don't want to remake
Raiders I don't want to remake
Terminator you know I think that there
there are their extension so those
movies sure I mean I think that you
could probably tell a decent jaws story
today but I would not want to remake
jaws because there's no there's no
upshot to it like it's a perfect thing
already Raiders is a perfect thing
already remaking it trying to replicate
greatness is a recipe for disaster
so yeah let's see but black-irish 83
what's my opinion on cyborg I'm a new 52
I must tell you black Irish I have none
those never the biggest cyborg fan I
tried to keep up with the new 52 but
that that was those a fool's errand for
me so I really have one I was I was
impressed with ray Fisher in Justice
League only because I don't care about
the character very much and so he's kind
of made me care about him and his attack
on the character was interesting and
what I expected so it's not that I don't
want more cyborg stories I just couldn't
tell you which one of the innovation
shoes and that was a mouthful mate made
lester 13 who's my favorite Bond Sean
Connery with Daniel Craig as number two
let's see
Phoenix 84 any interest in seeing a
Warrior's remake you know I not really
only because you know I wouldn't
understand the context for it you know
like it's it is such a New York story
tell told during the time at about a
time that was all about sort of warring
rival gangs in New York that don't exist
that way anymore so if it's a remake and
you're just going to do it again in the
70s I don't I don't know why why I don't
that doesn't argue for its existence in
a way that makes it worthwhile for me
but I don't know I'm sure somebody has a
great take for me on an urban Odyssey
story but I don't have one myself sorry
men everywhere double-o one the easiest
and hardest parts of screenwriting
easiest part not writing hardest part
actually write it now if you asked me
because it's easy to not be doing
anything if you ask me the parts that I
enjoy the most I would say the early
part of screenwriting when you're when
you're when you're still dealing with
the raw clay of it all when it's here's
this world that I love her here's this
character that I love or here's the the
germ of a story I want to tell and
flushing that out building
and and beginning to when you're in that
point where like if you'd if you if you
remember your Astro geometry or
astrogeology when when planets begin to
form and it's just all swirling hot
rocks and magma and they're all kind of
smash them together in ways that make
sense and some don't so they fly out for
the planet but you're you're slowly
accreting a ball of story and watching
that take shape and helping to get that
to take shape is my favorite part of it
that in writing the action scenes which
is fun my least favorite part is is it's
always at 2:00 it's always the middle
and it's always for me like the fourth
pass on a script like the first draft is
hard but lease is done and you can take
some some solace in that the second
draft you know what needs to be fixed
you know how to change you how to make
it better and then you give it to some
friends and they give you notes and then
you can implement those notes but after
a while the continuing to hammer at
something over and over and over again
and try to make it better incrementally
after a while you just like I don't I
don't know what to change here to make
it be anything I'm just moving commas
around and that is a kind of waste of
time but yeah so that's my favorite and
least favorite hey if let's see Stephen
Lizarraga I wanted to work towards being
a film producer in Hollywood what would
you say my steps would be to get there
if I don't know somewhere in the
industry well I mean there's a couple of
ways the way that I think will serve you
in the best stead is to find a friend
who wants to direct or write a movie who
you believe is talented and help that
person make that thing happen at the end
of the day that's what a producer does a
producer is helping will the thing into
being excuse me and is is helping to
execute the vision of somebody who has
vision most producers themselves are not
abundant with vision and that's okay
because there's another job some are
some are absolutely good story people
some are absolutely you know you know
green in a room and can absolutely help
to-to-to-to Midwife something along
but that is not inherently the producers
job but the producers job is to execute
the producers job is to help build the
producers job is to get the money and
the crew and make sure the trains run on
time
and make sure that you have everything
that you could possibly need to make a
movie happen that's the one way yes you
know that's the the Galen her James
Cameron way it's like you know he had an
idea for Terminator and she had the will
to make it happen and together they made
a movie you know that's the cab scott
motion way like Kev's got an idea for a
movie Scott helps make it happen the
other route is to go corporate is to is
to go work in the mailroom and an agency
and get promoted to agent and then go
you know work at at a studio in the mail
room or as a junior executive and then
slowly rise up the ranks and then get
some trust and work with a bunch of
people who are really smart and then
segue and become an independent producer
either at the studio you're working at
or someplace else but there's a
corporate route and there's the the sort
of indie find yourself a a thoroughbred
and help them race as well as they can
route I hope that helps
let's see the pupper at the gates have
done what music do I listen to I listen
to almost everything I'm going to pull
up my let's see blend up my iTunes now
and I will click on the column that says
plays and what play has been played the
most here are let's see the top are we
the top 10 bell-bottoms by the Jones
player Blues Explosion off of a baby
driver soundtrack black skinhead by
Kanye West doing it to death by The
Kills
hey kids boom Ava run the jewels don't
worry about a thing by Stevie Wonder
track 17 off of the John wick 2
soundtrack love and happiness by Al
Green are you mine by Arctic Monkeys
followed by rubella by Arctic Monkeys
and then
the next three are Beyonce hold up
6-inch and formation so basically I
listen to kind of everything soundtracks
R&B rock rap classic you name it if we
got a little further down in there we
would get to the Hamilton soundtrack but
yeah so it's a little bit of everything
um I'll coffee and bro nuts again what
is a phantom that people would be
surprised I am a part of AI it's hard to
tell only because I'm not I've never
been cautious about admitting any of my
particular fandoms I mean I'm a DMV fan
though I haven't played in 25 years but
Sauron sorcery is life's blood for me
Conan the Barbarian was Seminole West
Wing I have also not been shy of
admitting online that it is my it is
Mother's Milk great british baking show
maybe yeah I I love to see me I'll have
to watch me some Brits big stuff um
let's see mmm
Phoenix 84 now having boiled any get
goes lately I've been in recovery for
that so thanks for triggering let's see
blah blah
foghorn 37 DC animated movies do you
watch them wow that was very those very
Jules
English [ __ ] do you speak it I
don't watch many of them I watched a
bunch you know a few years ago but I
haven't seen like the last 10 or so so
yeah man I'm sorry about that
[Music]
let's see questions questions questions
Travis TSP can I think of any show that
has had as
out of the first season's iron fists and
had a good season to turn around
I said Levin I'm only an episode a half
into 250 zijn 2 so I can't say for sure
what it is but I will say that Parks and
Recreation the first season has got
awful and the second season begins the
the run of one of my favorite sitcoms
ever and I think you know depending on
how you feel about Seinfeld do not go
watch those first eight episodes because
they're they're horrendous I think there
are absolutely shows that have found
their their footing but most of those
shows did so in a entertainment
ecosystem that was not as clogged as
this one is there are too many shows so
some four hundred some-odd scripted TV
shows from the air any given year
compared to the 50 or 60 that were on
the air when Seinfeld started even the
200 that were on the air when Parks and
Rec started so the competition for
eyeballs are so steep counting on a
second season to get better feels
ill-advised to say the least so yeah I
hope I if the season two is good but but
most shows don't get that second chance
let's see protagonist radio what Marvel
Studios bear introduce me more in a post
up a man movie world or amazed that city
best I'm not sure but I think I think if
you're gonna introduce me more it asks
for you to be introducing the Fantastic
Four at the same time but I think
there's there's and I don't know what
the outcome and story is either but I
think if you're introducing me more you
introduce him as a bad guy so
introducing a king of Atlantis who's
done being the king of Atlantis and
wants to be the king of the world that's
a pretty good start I would I would
watch the you know Atlantis rising you
know conquering like Genghis Khan
the the world of the dry land earth and
then somebody's got to stop let's I mean
maybe yeah maybe all right let's see RJ
AAT 907 thoughts I'm Burt Reynolds death
I I grew up watching Burt Reynolds I
grew up with Smokey and the Bandit I
grew up with Hooper which is one of my
favorite movies I grew up with a
cannibal wrong which i think might have
been the first time that I ever saw
I like that he liked being an actor I
like that he didn't seem to be having
the most fun ever at being an actor he
was better than anybody gave him credit
for but had more fun than anybody I
think understood and I think that he he
was a rare bird and that he was he was
he was the most popular movie star or
and I think the 70s and 80s perhaps and
it's it's an astonishing run and he did
such great work even as stuff that
didn't need to be great but um and I
feel like we could use somebody like
that I think Clooney Clooney of ten
years ago was the closest we had to that
which was a guy who was handsomer than
he had any right to be but also a better
actor than anybody really thought he was
until he proved it and just seemed to me
I knew exactly who he was and it spent
time in in the quote-unquote ghetto of
Hollywood before he made it before he
made it big so always appreciated every
opportunity that he got and it seemed to
me having the most fun doing it
so yeah I he he will be missed
and I and I missed that kind of actor I
miss those kind of movies just we're
having a good time there's the the
pressure on it being phenomenal isn't
that high but the the good-natured
spirit of it is what makes it work so
yeah he shall be rest Matt will post
favorite lethal weapon lethal weapon one
I mean I like to the heart opener of two
is great
in the middle of a car chase but yeah no
one's my favorite um let's see Jessica
Faith X Jessica fav X watching while
nursing my week old son and he advised
for a new model by raising a man in this
world I you know I it is hard to know
before you meet the man that that man is
going to be but I would teach him to not
be afraid of who he is do not be afraid
of how he feels to be humble but let
[ __ ] know when he's good at
something don't rub it into people's
faces but prove how good you are at it
and to remember that every person you
meet and everything you do is a step on
the ladder of getting to where it is you
want always forward let's see foghorn
$37.00 watch Lucifer yes I love them
super it is one of the few shows that I
watch almost live because I have a love
for sort of goofy cop buddy shows with
some supernatural element I was also a
fan of castle on that supernatural home
it was Nathan Fillion so yes blabbity
blabbity blah protagonist radio can the
dark tower work as a TV series I know
that there are a couple of companies
that certainly hope so
and I think it's totally possible let's
see
lunchbox MC what are my thoughts on the
HBO show the leftovers
I appreciated the leftovers more than I
like the leftovers I know what they were
trying to do and the fact that they
achieved it is pretty great I think the
talent and assemble for that show is off
the charts but as a genre fan as a
person who loves science fiction and and
horror and that sort of thing I like my
stories to be a little bit more
objectively foundational meaning it
tells me what it is and plays by those
rules as opposed to never telling me
what it is and making up the rules as it
goes the only rule the leftovers had was
we're never to explain to you what
happened what the departure was and if
it's real or if it's not and then it
kind of did but yeah I just I longed for
first solid footing under me as I watch
the TV show and that was fundamentally
not about that let's see a moringa Sam I
gonna return first vote on the match
probably not for a while because I got a
day job the Ralph $23 watts always sunny
it's been a minute but uh I love the
first like four or five seasons and yes
Fabio 65 I still have that pen let's see
just podcast which came first writing
scripts or comics and what got you on
the train of writing the first thing I
ever wrote and finished was a feature
film script yeah that came first the
first thing I ever got paid to write was
prose and as a magazine editor and a
writer
the first fiction ever got paid to write
was a comic book strip but what set me
on the path to writing was I wanted to
be a filmmaker and especially in college
and yeah I was I wanted to be a
filmmaker in college and started making
student films and realized that nobody
cared as much about the films as I did
so assembly people that get them done
was hard even when I got to assemble
them and never turn out exactly the way
I wanted it to except on the page the
page you have total control over as a
writer it will it lives and dies by your
ability not anybody else's lack of
enthusiasm a commitment so that's that's
what made me want to be a writer so it
did it was always going to be as I
sought in my head
they were lasari not normal I never
listen to victory Boyd's on the broken
instrument let's see welcome to the rock
hey Nate protagonist radio do you think
America would be down for an American
battle royale remake well I mean that's
the hunger game so clearly they are
totally down um let's see sleepy smile
on 34 is there another SModcast show you
would like to guest on the mothership
man get me get me in this podcast yo
boom I'm the one media a favorite video
game I've ever played Wow gauntlet I've
never I've never felt quite as nervous
playing a game as warrior needs food
badly let's see I know like I know
you're a chicken but what kind of horror
would I create black mirror kinda hard
technology horror the [ __ ] that the [ __ ]
that sketches it's all around you not
about the jump scare but totally about
the finding finding the ordinary awful
yeah we'll do that
Macon's Ellis what'd you go to someone
writing or is it just a feeling I don't
have a single song then I write nine
times out of 10 it's a soundtrack just
because it's not even true because if
I'm in the zone the words don't bother
me but if I'm writing an action scene
having like action music on the
background helps if I'm just kind of
spitballing then it kind of doesn't
really matter and it doesn't really
matter
let's Bharat you do I use format program
to read scripts like final draft yes I
think use final draft it's awful
it's a horrible program that's way too
expensive and should be continually
updated for free instead of having to
pay for upgrades but it's also the
industry standard so you're a little
trapped by it that said fade in how
software people like scriptwriter how
software people like I haven't tried yep
I'm going to shortly Highland by John
August is a pretty good script format or
I've been told so so yeah yeah final
draft is a standard but hopefully not
for much longer
that's SVO gig what hip-hop artist what
I'd like to see a biopic for and who
would I cast
I think Slick Rick would be interesting
I think Slick Rick British rapper come
to the stage breaks big gets involved in
some shenanigans goes to jail comes back
out trusty reclaim his throne yeah I
just look Rick just saying leftovers eat
lunch box so I didn't care that much
about the leftovers [ __ ] when I told you
about Lucifer already man simmer down
simmer down now let's see seed pods some
of the final edits of books on Alex
Haley in the roots phenomenon we have
thoughts or memories about the legacy I
remember watching roots when it first
aired way back when of the day and it
was I mean I don't have to tell you that
it was a seminal moment in American
television and in race in America
because I don't think that very many of
any of white America at that time in the
late 70s had thought in any real way
about slavery it was it was a thing
and way back when though it's not that
way back when but they have never been
asked to empathize with the slave
narrative and so the the legacy of it is
huge but it's also somewhat I don't
wanna say futile because that's wrong
but today right now in this day and age
it feels that whatever sense of you know
mutual acknowledgement of that as a
foundational cause in the American
diaspora and the splintering of the
American people has been forgotten or at
the very least it's in the distant
memory so yeah there's a there's a ton
of uh there's a ton of thoughts to be
had more than will be had at this
particular moment see Drake central my
name is rose America podcast
occasionally there'll be some idea in
the back of my head better think about
but they mmm again the free time thing I
guess hope so I would like to at some
point we'll see I'll end a prequel in
Africa all right tell me a lot of stuff
sure let me do that oh hi mark
because filling is my magical um shut up
Harrison oh I haven't seen any of ozark
although I've heard it's pretty awesome
how do I feel about Henry Cavill yeah
let's see speed of Rod watched Neil
Gaiman to American Gods and so where I
think of it pretty sure we talked about
it at some point on on the big cast but
I did see all the first season I read
the book books loved the book like the
show I think that occasionally it got a
little indulgent but in a way that was
least interesting to watch in its
indulgence but but ya know I'm a fan hey
raka from Costa Rica Phoenix 84 to enjoy
attending San Diego comic-con I
they it's on a bell curve if it abscent
flows there are some years when I go and
I'm not entirely looking forward to it
but I once I get on the ground I'm
having a blast because I love it there
and there's some years that I'm actively
aggressively looking forward to going so
uh it ebbs and flows but every every
time I'm there I find some thing that
makes it awesome so yeah everywhere
double of one would set any morning
cartoon to make for a cool live-action
film I don't remember if galaxy rangers
was Saturday morning or just after
school but galaxy Rangers
I love it still love it alright let's
see I got five minutes left looking for
the goods
looking for the goods what did you miss
katana oh so much so much it's not even
funny yeah if you were to have any guest
star on famine on Batman who would it be
well we would need a time travel machine
because now it's fat man Beyond but
taking your question I would like to
push to see if we can get meal gaming on
the show that would be kind of great
we've already had filling on shad hair
would be kind of Awesome just to talk to
the Shatner levar burton would be sweet
maybe we can make that happen
lin-manuel Miranda if we could have
anybody I wouldn't want that
[ __ ] on the show cuz god damn it
this makes everybody else look like dim
bulbs in a bright room let's see Kate
ARSs what a my thoughts on disability
portrayed in films always needed a
miracle cure dead of learning how to
live with it
I do recall when I was in the office
room that was one
characters in the show Gary who is
autistic and and I have experienced with
autism I've been an autistic daughter
and I remember there was a storyline
where we wanted to temporarily cure him
and I fought really hard against it
because there is no cure
it is a thing you have that is the thing
you learn to live with that is you can
get better at dealing with it through
therapy and through treatment and
through drugs but you know and of course
every if you meet one person with autism
you've met one person with autism
because it manifests differently in
everybody and this of course was science
fiction but the idea of being able to
cure a person that would never be cured
in any real way really kind of bothered
me so yes I do not like this sort of
miracle cure storyline
unless it's a fantasy disease that
you're making up and you're coming up
with a reason why you figured out how to
cure this magic disease but if it's a
real thing in the real world you know no
that doesn't work for me let's say let
me fast forward a bit
this walks with purpose we have had
Grant Morrison he is pretty great
let's see Romy seven one eight nine one
when are you and Kevin gonna do a show
at c2e2 me you know it's funny I would
love to do a show at c2e2
I would love to do a show almost
anywhere it requires somebody booking a
show and requires somebody reaching out
and saying hey we would love for you
guys to do a show at our comic book
convention would you be willing to do
that and we will say okay uh hear their
conditions through which we would agree
to that and they will either agree to
those conditions or not and we will ever
then get on a plane or not but it's it's
rarely a matter of us deciding to not go
to a place or deciding on our own to do
a fat man at a place and somebody's
gotta bring us somebody's gotta book us
somebody's got a somebody's got to pay
the freight to get these boys in their
house so uh so if you would like us to
do a show at c2e2
I would tell c2e2 I would tell you know
get on that Twitter or find a name
but like hey you know what I think
there's a big great idea me and a
hundred of my friends but about tickets
just to come see that that that could
move a needle more than are saying hey
you don't be fun there we went to
Chicago and it our soul say yes there
you have de crown sir but I'd rather
watch Harriet Tubman Demon Slayer or
black Buffy reboot
i I do not know very much about Harriet
Tubman Demon Slayer I'd love the idea a
little bit of Demon Slayer but that also
feels to me a little bit like Abraham
like in vampire hunter which wasn't that
great I would just like to Harriet
Tubman movie just give me one of those
just tell that story
I don't need demons in that story for
that story to be amazing but I think
there's there's there's things to say in
doing in black Buffy then I'm also very
curious of that I I could go either way
I can go either way am i up to date on
any comics or trade rating anything I am
so far behind on comics it's not even
funny and I will just count my
embarrassment right there hey Shan you
yellowhammer
needs a support group from the show I
don't know which show but ok I think my
friends I will have to call it here yeah
I gotta go do a thing at 6:30 and it's
6:15 and I gotta I gotta be on my way I
gotta be on my way but this is fun and
we'll keep doing these and and hopefully
this will end up in the feed and for
those who were not part of it you will
get to see what you all missed maybe you
won't maybe this is just for you I don't
[ __ ] know I can't see into the future
I wish I could I would have made far
less mistakes but yes you guys have fun
you'd be good I will see you I'll see
you when I see you all right guys
[Music]
you